you give people the data you empower the  people and this popular support have  motivated China's policy of great great  the government changed its plan for  renewable energy is there a giant push  towards solar and wind piers at the next  step  China's got some of the biggest wind and  solar companies in the world now even  though China has some of the largest  challenges like huge population China's  gonna prioritize wind and solar  rather than coal  but China can do it and I think the rest  of the world can  China is still heavily relying on fossil  fuels but they seem to be transitioning  to renewables much faster than anyone  anticipated